the IRS it has now come out that they
were targeting the Tea Party and other
Tea Party related organizations they
were using phrases when they were
hunting down organizations such as Tea
Party Patriots 912 which is Glenn Beck's
organization and they flagged over a
hundred tea party related applications
and people are justifiably not happy
about this now I'm gonna guess and I
know both of you pretty well but you're
not big Tea Party chicks but that you're
not gonna be happy about this and are
you why do you think I'm not a big tea
party chick I just I go to those rallies
and get wasted with all these crazy-ass
right-wingers no that does set me apart
I think that it definitely has been a
bad week for Obama I don't know whether
or not the Obama administration actually
played a role in this and I don't really
understand why the IRS would be
politically motivated but if there is
evidence indicating that they are doing
something that's politically motivated
that I'm against it I don't think that
they should do that I think the IRS
doesn't make sense to me because I feel
like they're serious instances of like
you know unlawful tax deductions
whatever it is and then they always go
after little guys right and so that
always rubs me the wrong way but then
this too like you just you can't act as
a politically motivated you know
Department you have to you know audit
organizations that are doing something
that's unlawful right so before you jump
in it does seem to me that this was
clearly politically motivated because if
it wasn't politically motivated they
might have gone after Media Matters or
some some left-wing things so political
motivation can we expect anything here's
what you're all missing yes okay they
look for red flags to audit you might be
an audit in three times because I take a
lot off for travel and entertainment and
you know three times I've never owned a
penny but I have been audited you have
to go through a lot and it's fun isn't
it fun so horrible and you know who
makes money is the tax repairs because
they have okay now they look for red
flags is this a red flag
you're picketing with a sign that says I
don't pay taxes
of course they're auditing the Tea Party
these idiots are walking around at these
big wooden sites don't pay taxes we're
against taxes I don't pay attack hello I
don't think it's anything about which
party they're going guys no pain is
taxes so they should have expected it
actually a flag they're saying I think
we should it's not political oil they
just they see a fish on the line and
that's it right do you think though
there's a danger in that you know I mean
that there's because there is you're an
idiot someone might look at you well
that the government that maybe they
shouldn't that they shouldn't be just
targeting one side you know I always get
pulled out of the line at the airport
just so they can pull out the soir the
dark haired man next to me and not be
accused of racial profiling so what
you're saying is they're supposed to
audit me again just so they cannot at
the tea party know audit the idiot is
walking around with a big sign in public
saying I'm against paying taxes see if
you can get any money that way do you
think this is like a case of Star Wars
obi-wan Kenobi saying to Darth Vader if
you strike me down I'll come back more
powerful than you can possibly imagine
because that seems to me what they might
have done here with the tea party it's
like they're giving the tea party
exactly what they want this is the part
of the story that annoys me the most
because now you have these right-wing
pundits saying senior do bomb
administration everything's a big
conspiracy theory right and this is
working out perfectly for them because
even though it makes my blood boil and I
get dizzy just thinking about it right
now
you know politicians are prepping for
2016 right and so the Republicans are
making their list of things that they
can use to attack the Democrats and this
is a perfect example right oh look look
at what the IRS did under the Obama
administration oh look at how Hillary
Clinton handled Benghazi you know
Hillary Clinton is likely to run in 2016
yeah and we'll get to that discussion in
just a little bit but I hate that now
the Conservatives have something that
they can use to their advantage to their
own political advantage yeah yeah it's
so true they can actually know when
we're running say oh gosh a few people
died in an embassy and a few people got
audited and all we have to fight back
with his
gee they put us into two illegal Wars
for no reason
they could have prevented 9/11 he knew
it was coming
thousands of Americans died millions of
Iraqis and now G we know but Democrats
are notoriously bad at campaign
maybe we'll get better I hope so I
certainly hope so
yeah I get better and you know I just
think being Benghazi is gonna become a
drinking game you know how many times
can you say this word and not may the
only way they're gonna make Benghazi
stick as if they can just actually say
Benghazi got oral sex and then people
will think about it
Lenovo's is the official outfitter of
the Rubin report I want to put you in
this shirt go to bonobos calm enter code
TR are to zero for twenty percent off
your first purchase